he's a four-time pro bowler he's in the
ten third ten thousand yard rushing club
he's one of our favorite guests as well
and i know i've been saying that a lot
but it's the truth we just had michael
irvin on now we have the head coach of
tennessee state football
eddie george how are you eddie george
man i'm doing great brother how are you
happy new year happy new year to you too
uh how do you like the coaching thing
how do you like it you know i love it
man i i really do i never thought in all
my years of playing and since i've been
retired for
15 some odd years that um i would find
so much joy
in coaching i mean there are
the days where it's frustrating and long
hours and film study and recruiting and
fundraising and all of that but
it's so gratifying when you start to see
these kids buy in and get it and see
success and see the smile on their faces
the appreciation the the the um
thank yous that you get from the players
like coach thanks for being hard on me
thanks for your your advice
i mean to give back to the game that
gave me so much
um it's it's it's so awesome so
gratifying i now understand why they say
it's addicting when you coach it really
is it's a wonderful calling
um i'm glad that god chose me to do this
and um it's been uh it's been phenomenal
so far so yeah i i know when we last
spoke you had just taken the job and you
were talking to me about
your process your thought process about
taking it and why and your concerns
about all the other stuff you know i i'm
i'm sure it's not any surprise to you
how much you love the competition and
love seeing others succeed based on your
uh your program that you have laid down
i'm sure that that might not surprise
you what about the other stuff though
now that you're into it eddie wow the
other stuff this is a day-to-day
challenge richard and i and i just sum
it up to this you have to meet
mediocrity at every turn
that's whether it's on the field from
your players from your coaches
from the training staff from the
equipment
to training table at every single turn
and raise the stakes and raise the
standard a higher standard for what you
want what it's going to become my goal
is to make this program a world-class
program through football
um to impact our students in a much
greater way than just athletics but the
holistic person um academics uh
spiritually speaking to become a better
person so all those things that we're
meeting with facilities and
having to um
just get the the bare bones of uh of
things in terms of infrastructure like
uh um a football operations building you
know that's exciting to me that we're
finding the capital we're raising the
money we are
in process of building all this stuff
out
that to me is are the wins that's what's
going to
bring sustainability to our this program
and hopefully we'll have a few
championship seasons within that so
it's it's a long process rich it's a
it's a tedious one it's frustrating
because
academia they move at their own pace
you know sure uh and you got to
understand that but
it's really a collaborative effort and
to understand and then be understood and
then finding that middle ground of how
can we move
this ball forward how can we roll in the
same direction and and it really is uh
it's a good deal when you're when you're
making some headway eddie george here on
the rich eisen show head football coach
of tennessee state football uh i i'll
ask you i know i'm talking about a
competitor uh when it all comes down to
it but also you know prime from way back
in the day when you were playing ball
together seeing the recruits that he's
bringing to jackson state your your
thoughts on that in terms of maybe
do you look at it as it lifts all hbcu
boats or or what what do you think about
all this it definitely does without a
doubt i mean i talked to dion a lot i
talked to dion and during the process of
me you know trying to figure out whether
i was going to do this or not and we
talked you know
maybe
once a week um
just to see how he's doing i know he had
some some issues and he was told i was
praying for him but um but more
importantly you know he's telling me
best practices and
things that he's done to be successful
and the bottom line is this you know
off the field
our goal is to
raise the profile raise the standard of
hbcus and say hey you know what
you don't necessarily have to go to the
power five schools to get to your end
goal you can come to an hbcu you can
come to a different school
and be be all that you want to be and be
very successful at if you can if you
have aspirations of going to the next
level and playing on the next level
they're going to find you you know we
have the resources to do that we can we
have the coaching to do that we can
coach guys for that level
um so when i see him
going after you know school players that
are
going to ohio state or michigan or
florida state and able to bring them
there
that's what it's all about because
now it opens up the door
uh pandora's box for others other kids
who say hey you know what
let me explore what else is out there
tennessee state alcorn state grambling
state hugh jackson's down there uh
jackson state so it just opens the door
in terms of kids saying hey there are
other options and i can still have a
wonderful career i can still attain all
the things i want to do but i'm going to
do it differently i dare to be different
and what's your what's your approach for
transfer portals and things like that
and recruits and uh whether it's just uh
high school recruits or transfer portal
what what's your what's your formula on
all that eddie george well well the
ratio is 40 40 20. that's what prime
city and and right now it's
uh bringing bodies in the building that
can play period you know i gotta find
players that are dogs
they can hunt they can they can run that
has that has uh some um some some split
some ball in them that they played
before some experience
and i can win now at certain positions
and then there are the the 20 which is
the high school kids that i want to
develop
i'm not so interested right now just to
developing kids and drafting you know
just uh
recruiting all high school kids you know
that that i have to find players that
can play now and find that right mix
that right ratio and as time goes on
that ratio will slide and be fluid and
go to 50 50 and hopefully a 60 40 ratio
to where we have sustainability but on
the front end
i've got to flip my roster and find guys
that can come in that are looking for an
opportunity to play they're looking for
an opportunity to be coached by
world-class coaches i've coached every
single level and have a chance to go
uh to play the next level we just had a
couple kids that's playing um in the nfl
pa bowl um rory rahman is going to be uh
playing uh on the nfl network of the
nflpa bowl um jeremy hickbottom who was
our quarterback will be in the hbcu um
uh bowl as well
and um we're just really excited for
their future yeah no no there's the hbcu
combine that's coming up as well so you
know get this pipeline going here and
get the infrastructure as you point out
you know uh going into direction and and
it appears to be going in that direction
a little bit too and it's going to be
kind of
how does it feel to be walking into you
know the home of the titans to coach
your your team i mean you're you're all
your old stomping grounds i mean that's
got to be something else for you eddie
right
coach george where where you know where
where player george used to bark at ray
lewis all the time and more others you
know i mean that's got to be wild for
you you know
it is it is wild because uh it brings
back so many memories of me playing as a
player
and it's it's a special place a place
where i haven't lost a lot of ball games
i told my team that i said look you know
i have not lost a lot of games in this
building as a player and i haven't i'm
not i'm damn sure we're not gonna do it
as a coach
so
there is a standard in which we listen
we defend our home we have a winning
record at home
and um
now in this capacity where i'm at
coaching i'm
walking up and down the sidelines of the
headset i have to pinch myself sometimes
like i am really
coaching in a ball game right now and i
have to call timeout because
you know we got to get the right playoff
or we got to get you know my defense has
to get rest i mean i'm just looking at
the game from a different lens and
that's been a lot of fun you know it
really has do you uh run into vrable a
lot
at all eddie no i i haven't i haven't
talked to ray i haven't i don't run into
him a lot because of kobet right um but
we've we've been texting back and forth
and it's my plan to go in there and and
to soak up some knowledge from him
he should be the he should be the
um coach of the year coach of the year i
know i really do believe that he got my
he i mean i i i gave a vote to peter
king it's not the one that counts for
the award but but he's i mean what he's
done i mean derek henry
uh out since out since october uh aj
brown out quite a bit julio jones has
not been the the julio in atlanta that
they hope to have acquired
from atlanta and they're still the one
seed i mean it's unbelievable
it is it is remarkable what they what
he's done not just made the playoffs
but
95 players that has gone on their roster
this year i think that's an nfl record
and they're the number one seed you
would think a team like that that's
decimated with that many injuries
would be an eight or nine eight eight
and nine team just trying to squeak in
the playoffs they're a number one seed
beat quality teams
and he's spent the last three four or
four years implementing his system
and we're seeing that system work no
matter who you plug in
it works whether it's dante freeman
uh another running back that you can
just plug in there they're able to run
the football with physicality at the
line of scrimmage at the offensive line
they finally got a defensive pass rush
that is nasty
and the secondary's playing well they're
playing complementary football rich and
for the national audience yeah they're
not the sexy picks some people are
surprised that tennessee titans are the
number one seed in afc yeah
because they play complimentary football
and they've beaten quality teams
throughout the year so we'll have to
wait and see with how it all unfolds in
the playoffs you know who finished ninth
in the league in rushing with 937 yards
ninth top ten in the league and rushing
is derek henry
you know right isn't that amazing in
eight games he ran for 937 yards and he
finished in the top 10 and he hasn't
played
in 10 weeks it's nuts it's crazy
i know he is truly unbelievable uh did
you before i let you go last two
questions did you see last night's
national championship game um in
indianapolis and if so what are your
what are your thoughts on that one oh
well yes of course i love college
football
watching it love growing and learning uh
first of all before i go into that
congratulations uh no no no no no no let
me handle the interview eddie let me
handle the interview
i will handle the interview
don't know be careful
be careful no no
but you're the interviewee i'm the
interviewer
what'd you think of georgia's win what
did you i thought it was coming next
hey but but last night was a thrill to
watch it was uh a lovely defensive
battle for three quarters
until everything opened up at the end of
what a gutsy performance by
georgia um
the defense stepped up time and time
again giving the office a chance to find
themselves and and uh they i'm really
proud i'm really happy for kirby smart
and and the georgia program for so many
years they've been trying to cross that
threshold of winning a championship you
know year after year they had the talent
but they can't get over the hump of
alabama and finally they got over that
hump and it was just a great game to
watch i know and i kind of as i said at
the top of the show it's kind of
interesting that even with the you know
the world of nil and five-star recruits
and there were like a hundred of them on
the field last night it was a kid who
had to go on his own journey you know
walked on junior college
you know in between stints at georgia
who won it at quarterback that kids
that's in bennett iv was dropping some
dimes you know what i mean like that was
something else last night it really was
how about that throw to
really set things off
yeah that left it along with the 50-yard
throw i mean he was struggling you know
holding onto the ball and he got kind of
wide-eyed it was like that almost that
feeling of oh here we go again you know
alabama has his number but he persevered
and that was great to see all right now
let's get to the one thing out so i you
know your season's over your season was
over and you're like all right one last
saturday i'll watch a football game and
um
snow's coming down in ann arbor and i i
finally get to chat with you
awful win
uh eddie george off a w yeah well how's
that feel i mean it's been over a decade
right
since you had that opportunity how does
it feel for you to do that it felt great
by the way i felt great it was great i
was living my best life eddie i'm sure
you know again you're
you're you're you're doing your thing i
was just so excited for ohio state
beating duke and basketball two days
later ceiling
ceiling
sealing your newfound level of
basketball school that was great um
yeah now where basketball is going well
clearly clearly you beat duke that was
big for you guys they almost stormed the
court that was great no you know yeah
yeah i mean you get those victories that
happens every once in a blue moon you
know so
yes that's a once in a blue moon for
michigan once every 15 years
you know you will give you all that you
know y'all were due for that so i was
happy for honestly i was happy for the
for your your program thank you sir um i
have to admit that all blue uniform is
sweet i was like
i love it
i said okay miss i said i i hate your
guts but as a head coach and
uniforms i was like that all blue looks
pretty nice
i know it's part of your car it's part
of your current color scheme is it not
right
it really you know you know what the
crazy part is god has a funny sense of
humor
our tagline now is go blue
i have to say that
you know
i'm not gonna have to confirm it like go
blue
no csu did you
this may be a tradition um but
have you at least a split second say you
know when i got start getting some uh
tenure here we're gonna have to change
that like honestly deep down oh no
question
that's the number one thing that we are
going to change and i'm working on it
now
it's going to be go tigers i can't that
big it's hard for me to even get it out
i it
sometimes but
you know it's it's all good man
mysterious ways huh gear too man i gotta
send you a helmet or
take it love it on the show love it in
do it let's do it please any time uh
eddie george this isn't anytime uh
whenever you have time i'd love to
whatever any time you want to come on or
or send me whatever you want and go and
and uh go blue go blue
[Laughter]
right go big blue tigers oh you're
supposed to say it back to me supposed
to say it back to me you're blue
not not from which it comes from you how
it's coming from you i know the intent
behind that big blue no
you reject the spirit when you believe
it is intended i understand i get it i
get it good to chat with you eddie
you'll be well you'll be welcome all
right rich have a good day man you guys
eddie george
go blue
oh baby that's funny
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here